en el aeropuerto internacional ben
gurion de tel aviv aterrizó del air
force one con el presidente
estadounidense de joe biden a bordo
dando inicio a su primera gira por medio
oriente desde su llegada a la casa
blanca una gira que se extenderá hasta
el sábado y que lo llevará por israel
los territorios palestinos y arabia
saudita en esta primera alocución junto
al primer ministro israelí yair lapid y
al presidente israelí isaac herzog los
tres destacaron la histórica amistad
entre israel y eeuu y esa alianza
estratégica con el foco principalmente
en la defensa y un enemigo en común que
es irán bardem también destacó que esta
es su décima visita israel una zona que
conoce a la perfección desde aquella
primera visita en 1973 como senador algo
que también fue reflejado en las
palabras de lápiz quien definió a bailén
como un amigo y también con un sionista
pese a no ser judío mientras que ejerzo
comparó el liderazgo de bailén con la
figura bíblica de jose tras estos
primeros discursos la primera actividad
involucró a la visita de herramientas de
defensas de israel aquí en el propio
aeropuerto principalmente un sistema de
defensa láser contra misiles el llamado
hay también para que israel pretende
aumentar la inversión estadounidense
esta primera jornada de baile se va a
completar con una visita al museo del
holocausto yad vashem antes de que
mañana se mantenga las primeras
reuniones de alto nivel con lápiz con
gerson y con el líder opositor benjamín
netanyahu y luego para el viernes está
reservada la visita a los territorios de
palestinos antes de partir a salarial
hacia arabia saudita para culminar esta
gira con una reunión con los países del
golfo